so tell me dojo how
how did it affect your life how did it
change your life oh man i mean i've been
in and out of it over probably the last
10 or 11 years so i really started my
senior year
of high school um i got involved
i i fell victim to some guy really like
peddling stuff and he was teaching stuff
out of a book and then i got involved
with like a real master and a guy that
was teaching really great stuff but what
are you training like what do you do
so i do a little bit of um jiu jitsu
um you know the stuff the place i go to
in new york
is a gracie jutsu uh affiliate so they
teach
you know it is top tier it is you know
the jiu jitsu is rolling right yeah it's
and it's either ghee or no gi
um what's really surprising about that
is especially if you talk to
like law enforcement officers and guys
that are in the field a lot of guys
think
that the right way to go is well i'm
just gonna do nogi and get shorts and a
t-shirt because
that's how most people like i'm going to
get into i'm
am i going to get into a fight or if i'm
going to crap with somebody
but the things that you learn with a
ghee
are you learn how to grab stuff you
learn how to grab clothes you learn how
to i mean you could choke somebody out
using their t-shirt if you know the
right place to do it and know the right
leverage points
so and most guys can't do that like in
your estimation what percentage of the
male population do you think could
if if the need should be called upon
them to be lethal
actually defend themselves and somebody
that they might be with
less than ten i'd say between five and
seven if not
less [ __ ] it's small right so
just so guys like the sport is now and
how popular i mean
there's right you're two gyms all over
the place and stills i mean
like you know when i talk about learning
combat sports and pick something
boxing krav maga you just i i don't care
karate like whatever it is
you like pick something and just go do
it because as he just stated and i'd
estimate it's probably about the same
probably about 90 percent of the
population doesn't know how to fight
okay we've got no idea what they're
doing they'll talk about it but they
don't know how to actually fight and be
lethal
and guess what you have an air of
confidence around you when you know you
can [ __ ] somebody up
okay you may not win but at least you're
gonna like
go down fighting right yeah 100
i mean it's just even when i see guys
coming into the gym for the first time
you know i've been going to the same
place since i've been in new york
about six years and so i'm i'm a guy
that they put me with a lot of the new
guys and you know
i'm a pretty good you know pretty good
what's that are there any losers in
dojos
there are some but what happens to them
over time they get carved out of wood
man if they put in the work if they
stick around
and use two like it's it's humbling
that's the biggest thing it's super hot
there's no losers in dojos on a
long-term basis they either leave
and they quit or they do the work and
they level up it's impossible for you to
surround yourself with
low-tier low-value men because by
because by definition if you're moving
your ass from your house to a dojo to
learn how to be an effective
combat striker guess what other guys are
motivated too
and then you just kind of like level
yourselves up right and it's a great
environment for guys
you know no one's there to laugh at you
no one is there to judge
there's no there's you know even places
where
a guy like fitch would go and train i
mean those guys are
legit looking out for each other because
it's you know
it's i never understood guys that would
even at the gyms like you're making fun
of the guy who's in there and he's
overweight like he's in the [ __ ] game
man like he's at least there putting in
the worst
game deserves a pat on the back um you
know
so but but yeah so the va i've always
had positive experiences even with high
level guys and it's one of those things
too
especially jujitsu where you can go
really hard um but the in
the injury chance is super super low
because it's just you know it's called
the gentle art for a reason
i mean i think every guy i was talking
to chad about this chat oh i'm not gonna
say his name but he's a he's a guy in
the community and
but um super high level in like three
different disciplines i think he has
like three or four different black belts
i mean the guy's a
stone cold killer and it's you got to do
you got to learn some sort of stand up
you got to learn some sort of ground you
got to
you you just got to do you got to learn
striking too like you got to learn how
you have to learn
because man if you don't use for
striking kickboxing unboxing what do you
use
i do a little bit of mostly mine's like
dutch style kickboxing
so i do boxing man i love [ __ ]
throwing punches yeah
it's a combination a little bit of both
focus pads partner drills we do like
raising focus mitts and stuff
yeah so that's always a lot of fun and
then we put chin pads on and kind of go
nuts and do a little bit of sparring for
for the higher level guys but what it
also does is it
it really helps you hone in on learning
your body and how it moves and how to
control yourself
and you know you can really you can
really pick out the beginners from the
guys that know what they're doing guys
are like
super like really gripping tight and
they're like just really stoned and guys
don't know how to throw a punch and
they're like angling their wrists like
this
i mean it's super super easy to see who
knows what they're doing who they're not
um and the confidence thing is huge and
you can always tell
the most part i always always say this i
think it's such a funny thing about
fitch because you know he's one of the
most soft-spoken guys on
the entire rules role zero panel if not
the most
and he's a guy that could literally kill
a man with his bare hands in under 10
seconds
probably right because but it's you know
when you see these guys in the street oh
like what the [ __ ] man like let's go
let's go let's you know what's up like
those are the guys that don't want to
fight
it's the guy yeah i mean like well i
mean when you see the guys with the
cauliflower ears you know that you got
somebody that's
that's at least taking beatens and
probably you know go the other way if
you see that
like turn yeah all right so
so that's combat sports um i'm going to
hop on to the last three or four i got
left over but i'll see you later okay
bro
you got it all right thanks for hopping
on man of course yeah and um if you guys
don't know moff has
a show that he does on the stereo app
just just search for moff m-o-f-f i've
i've hopped in once before
um i think lately he's he's been
breaking down some of the chapters
in my book
you